[Music]
Carson Wentz joining us here
how you feeling feeling good he survived
yeah it was it was a blast yeah I made
it through and it was a blast this year
fortunately we were done earlier than I
then I would like to wish but uh it was
a great year what would you tell
yourself now if you could seven months
ago you know talk to that Carson once
seven months ago
um just enjoy it and embrace it you know
because as a as a player you know you
get caught up in the busyness of
everything and at times we can just fly
by right in front your face and so I
tried to at least you know take a big
step back every now and then and just
enjoy it and really realize you know
where I came from you know what there
was so much expectation you know when
the Eagles wants you and then they're
going to start you and then Bradford's
traded and then all of a sudden you're
in there yeah how much pressure do you
feel whether you show it or not how much
did you feel honestly not a lot because
I knew that's just that's just how I
like to play the game I like to just
play it and enjoy and have fun with it
but that's a tough city to be in no
pestilence yeah I know it but it's a lot
of fun a lot of fun when you're winning
and the passion you can just tell they
care they're you know the passion I have
so when you're winning and you know
throwing touchdown passes running out of
that tunnel it's pretty incredible
what was your welcome to the NFL moments
good or bad um I would say probably the
first driving and Cleveland the first
game of the year and positively you know
driving and driving down and throwing
that touchdown to Jordan it's kind of
from then on out for the rest of year I
was just all right it's just football
you know it's all everything is now kind
of over with everything settled now is
just let's just play ball but what was
tougher studying or the actual game
itself so the prep everything else
leading up to a game or when you got on
the field probably the prep because
naturally I mean you turn on the film
and you're going through the week and
it's a grind you know you're grinding
the tape and trying to figure out your
opponent and early in the week you're
like oh my gosh they do so much like
what are we going to do and then by the
end of the week you you feel confident
within everything so that's the
behind-the-scenes stuff that a lot of
people don't realize all right give me a
play that you called it the North Dakota
State in order to go to state
I've tried to forget a lot of that and
because it crosses over but uh but is it
similar and similar I guess the the
terminology is different but the the NFL
play seem really long yeah like it'll
take you ten seconds to say a play yeah
like give me a complex NFL play um man
putting me on the spot here
it's been a month spending months of
trying but you've already lost it no I
haven't lost it but I've tried to get
away from all those oh but no they get
they get long come and get me they get
long yeah banana why spider suppose we
watch our favorite shut up John yeah we
what the hell does that mean by the way
for that play you have to have John
exactly what he calls it that but it's
the protection it's the route it's a lot
of stuff but yeah there's a lot there's
a lot that goes into it but so at North
Dakota State you're running a pro-style
yeah plus you were under center and I
think it's it's underrated when when we
see these quarterbacks everybody's in
the gun now how much did that help you
being under center to make the
transition to the NFL yeah it helped me
a lot you know I I was comfortable with
it I'm not just being on the center but
you know calm plays in the huddle
getting to the line making protection
calls you know getting in and out of
plays all that stuff helped me so much
going into the NFL because it was second
nature you know from now if there's a
lot of guys that you got to learn all
that as well as the playbook as well as
a lot of stuff for me it was just
focused on the playbook does the rest is
kind of second nature already so that
helped me a ton I think it showed a
little bit this year we're talking to
Carson once joining us on behalf of
Gatorade you brought gifts I saw yeah
you don't have one yet all your get your
friends out here have one the other day
but yeah get rid they come up with this
new agx bottle I'm out with you up here
pretty cool tell your name on in
everything hopefully it motivates you to
maybe go to the gym a little more oh you
look great though
you look great but we all need it we all
need it yeah but anyway they're pretty
cool that you can personalize them
obviously you see last name you guys all
have your names on it former teams
everything now I calm these guys to a
spin class I can take you to a spin
class yeah see what you got
I kicked my button that I'm the Tom
Brady of sprinkler yeah I'd like to see
it yeah I'd like to see it and we night
19 I got a new bottle for it you have on
oh absolutely yeah oh this is making a
debut tomorrow it's Pinklon kidding me
I'm going to be the envy of the soul
cycle there what do you do in the off
season now you say you're trying to get
away from football yeah
hunting hunt a little bit you know
obviously you got to relax yes your your
friends and family a little bit but I've
been chomping at the bit a little bit to
get back at it but I'm still figuring
out the OP see I'm not gonna lie this is
the first time in a long time that I've
had time off like this so I'm still
trying to make you know make the best
decision and still keep football kind of
in the in the head in the headlights and
everything but I treated differently now
even though people are trying not to
treat you differently in terms of social
thing yeah yeah no question I mean it's
different but two people that know me
friends and family like I'm still the
same guy but you were famous in college
locally local yeah like you were a big
deal yeah
on a smaller scale right yeah didn't you
describe yourself as the George Clooney
of Fargo or something like honors that
literally never says oh you never really
never said my bad
Molly who was that who says Oh Josh
Duhamel the actor Josh Duhamel Jimmy
Garoppolo said that about Charleston
Illinois Oh Jimmy Garoppolo the Brad
Pitt of a villain Oy but you know the
your friends you want them to treat you
the same that be the seaman but then
they start to think about that right is
it a little awkward it's different at
times you know no question that's kind
of part of it but for people that know
me that have been a part of my life for
a long time I'm still the same to the
same guy you know nothing's really
changed you know maybe to the world you
know there's a lot there's a lot more to
it but I'm still I'm still the same
Carson once I grew up in North Dakota
most extravagant thing you bought
boy pretty pretty low-key with that
other than a new car other than that is
about it did you buy like a sensible
sedan or something like you didn't get
anything trick down or nothing real
crazy
nothing recognized Ford or you know gets
good gas mileage kind of thing ah
something like that yeah but we had a
quarterback draft in when was that it
was a right after the third week in the
season we had the quarterback draft and
Todd Fritz and the green shirt here had
the first overall pick down we have the
audio if you want it okay so you could
take any quarterback but he had to be
your quarterback the next seven years
everybody is on the board there now this
is he had Prince he had the first pick
and this is how that quarterback draft
with Prince you have the number one
choice in the draft and this is starting
your team right now your quarterback is
with number one pick and the jam Patrick
shows us I am impressed with what I've
seen the last two weeks especially last
night Carson yeah he was early on the
bandwagon in your professional career
Paulie was early on the bandwagon in
your college career the way he was taken
charge and very painting Manning s dare
I say o manic studies just changing
plays and he's just he was in control
like he had been playing for several
years and I'm like this guy's got
something and he's just getting started
he's already telling everybody what to
do and I'm gonna check this one off
oh okay calm down okay so we got here
who was your idol growing up I was a big
fan of Brett Favre it loved watching him
play but there are a lot of Packer fans
in North Dakota yeah there are a lot of
Vikings of bichri fans and I actually
grew up a Vikings fan so it's tough at
times to be a far fan but I just you
couldn't deny the way like I played the
game the mentality he had but you don't
play that way not not entirely not crazy
not entirely yeah he was he was he was a
gunslinger the definition I think I got
a little bit of that but not quite what
you level what you don't want too much
of that right I mean I'm not going to
argue against Brett Favre he's a 1 an
all-time great
have you met him not in person I'm
personal on his radio show once but oh
hopefully someday Oh coach Peterson's
friends of them so I'm sure I'll meet up
with him hopefully now when I ask for a
picture an autograph ha I'd probably
have to I'd probably have to fanboy you
might hear you you really a you would be
speechless probably would ya let me
probably go go hunting the other in your
favorite team lo the Packers are so far
but they really like a fan you know
you're used to heartache right a little
bit yeah yeah so I'm sorry I can that
can prepare you for Philadelphia as well
you know for a little while there huh a
little heartache there all right
congratulations spilled on my face
you got me all riled up you're a mess
yeah look at you you're flustered two
minutes really like I said Congrats on
the success and uh just remember just
remember the people who had your back
before anybody else did right here right
here in this room of those two not you
though now I jumped on I jumped on but I
remember seeing the North Dakota State
helmet on your show a while ago
appreciate oh yeah yeah we can write
them colors and I every probably uh
Polly was like Eastern stick man I go
okay I'm fine with that he's my boy
yeah and Pauly yo we got bison t-shirts
that were set into the man cave so yeah
we're of it right there love it now you
guys lost this year though I know that
was a tough one yeah yeah man I'm just
bringing up great things Ernie he's
Carson Wentz the Eagles quarterback he's
joining us on behalf of Gatorade thanks
for bringing the gifts and congrats yeah
did you have me all right we appreciate
that oh by the way can I do this Paulie
real quick yes oh yes we have your maybe
draft profile okay but you need to read
it okay okay are you capable doing this
I mean you can rethink I can read pretty
well yeah these are actual reviews of
Carson Wentz now I took out the positive
all right everybody in fact our next
guest Drew Brees did this and drew kept
his negatives he want to use it as
motivation last year so so who wrote
this Paulie gathered this from NFL
writers I have the names if you want
them later on you later
okay all right well here are your
weaknesses you go rate weaknesses needs
more consistency on anticipatory throws
outside the hash will get caught locking
in on target bringing secondary charging
in to make a play on the ball
inconsistent footwork in the pocket can
be a little flat with his downfield
touch throws everyone's all over the
place of that criticism there sometimes
the two plasma Vanessa my darts like it
can't please anybody anyway half has to
eliminate nonchalant throws into tight
quarters football when rolling out when
rolling out will float it a little much
when taking shots down the field allows
passing windows to quote to close
quickly when he's short arms his release
well while his arm strength is okay he
can still make all the throws and he can
make them with accuracy and the
comparison is to Blake bortles yep there
you go is there any truth in any of
those things I mean some you know I'm
not perfect by no means I'm not perfect
some but there's there's also some
things that people just you nitpick just
to have something right about yeah it's
kind of part of business but I mean I'm
not gonna argue with all of them there's
definitely we're all we're all works in
progress and you're ready to go you got
a lot of work done yeah I'll bring canal
I'll study it up and we'll be hopefully
getting better better reviews next year
quali I'll give you the names of those
writers on the way on these carson wentz
joining us on behalf of gatorade Thank
You Carson the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]